From cars that talk
to us when we're
lost, to houses that know when
we're too hot or too cold,
to phones that can
take our vital signs
and notify your
doctor, mobile apps
can do anything and everything.
What do you want your
app to do for your users?
Answering this
question will help
you decide what data to measure
and what insights you need.
With Google Analytics,
you have of a variety
of tools and
capabilities to give you
data about your
business and audience
so you can optimize
your app for success.
Be sure to spend
some time thinking
about what you need
to know about how
users interact with your app.
What insights would help
your app be smarter?
For example, if by
level two in a game
you've already lost over
50% of your traffic,
you'll need to take
a look at what's
happening for users while
playing that first level.
Depending on what
the analytics show,
you may want to add an
additional tutorial,
or make the levels
easier or shorter.
Here are some other questions
you may want to ask.
How many installs has
your app generated?
How much does each
download cost you?
Where did your
downloads come from?
Are your users high quality
and loyal to your app?
Do you want to achieve a
certain engagement time?
If you make a few tweaks
to your app interface,
would people be more
or less engaged?
When's the best time to
offer in-app purchases?
What's your user retention rate?
Whatever insights
you're looking for,
Google Analytics gives
you the data you need.
And Google Analytics
integrates directly with AdMob,
helping you understand your
users and their behavior
right in the AdMob interface.
By implementing Google
Analytics in your mobile app,
you can start collecting
data for things
like audience analytics,
attribution modeling,
conversion tracking,
and even re-marketing.
With Google Analytics,
you can find out
how often your app is
downloaded and installed,
and how successful certain
marketing campaigns are
in attracting visitors.
Want to know how users
are finding your app?
Google Analytics provides
app specific metrics
so you can learn more about
your user acquisition.
Google Analytics helps
you answer questions
like which operating
system do my new users use,
and where are they
located geographically?
Which traffic sources are
bringing the most new users?
What is my cost per
download, broken down
by each of my
marketing initiatives?
What's the ROI of my
marketing efforts?
You can access information
about the campaigns
that you're running via the
advertising and campaign
performance report.
There you can find data about
all traffic sources and gain
insight into how many new users
and downloads each campaign
generated, the
number of sessions
that took place, the
average session duration,
as well as whether or not
you're achieving your goals
and generating revenue.
OK.
So now you have successfully
gained new users
and are growing
your app downloads.
But now what?
After people discover
your app, it's
key to understand
their behavior.
How are they engaging
with your app?
What actions are they taking?
Are they doing what
you want them to do?
What are they purchasing?
How is this related
back to their behavior?
Answering these questions
will help you monitor and grow
your app success.
Google Analytics helps
you do just this,
by defining user segments based
on any metric or dimension
being measured in your app.
So using conditions
and sequences,
you can create
segments that are as
detailed and specific as
you'd like them to be.
You can apply these segments
on all of your reports
within Google Analytics.
So here's an example.
You can create a
segment of users
who have, say, spent at
least $10 in your app
and engaged with it at least
once in the last 30 days.
From there, you could apply this
to any Google Analytics report,
such as the e-commerce
product performance report.
And that will allow you to
see which items the users
are actually spending
their money on.
Another example,
suppose you want
to find out which section
of your app is most popular.
You can then use
this information
to create similar content.
With the behavior
reports, you can
find lots of
valuable information
about user activity,
from aggregate metrics,
such as average time spent
on a particular screen,
to the behavior flow, which
helps you understand how users
move between different screens,
to the crashes and exceptions
report.
So let's say we're looking
at the behavior flow report.
What you might notice is that
there are big areas where
people are dropping off.
So based on this
data, you might try
to improve these
areas so that people
are less likely to leave
your app before completing
the task you'd like them to.
If you sell products in your
app via in-app purchases
or on your own
store, you'll also
want to keep track of
what people are buying.
With the e-commerce
functionality,
you can gain insight into the
customer's path to purchase,
like when customers
added items to the cart,
began the checkout
process, completed
a purchase, and perhaps
most importantly,
identify segments of
customers who are falling out
of the shopping funnel.
Thanks for watching.
Be sure to check out
our other AdMob videos,
subscribe to our channel, and
visit google.com/admob for even
more information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]